tropical storm hannah which could bring
life-threatening storm surge and flash
flooding as it barrels towards southern
texas
it will likely make landfall as a
hurricane this afternoon or early
evening
the impact of the storm has already sent
large waves crashing off the coast of
galveston
hanna could dump up to 15 inches of rain
in some areas
and is one of just three major tropical
systems we are following this morning
tropical storm gonzalo
is bringing heavy rain and gusty winds
that moves closer to the southern
windward islands such as saint vincent
and the grenadines and hurricane douglas
is expected to make landfall in hawaii
this weekend
meteorologist jeff veradelli is here and
is very busy jeff good morning
that is for sure good morning jeff good
morning everybody
this season is off to a blazing record
pace about 10 to
10 days or so ahead of the old record so
let's start out with hannah and talk
about hannah
right now hannah has winds right around
70 miles an hour so in moments it could
become
a hurricane it's about 90 miles to the
east of corpus christi right now
hurricane warnings
storm surge warnings are in effect the
biggest threat is going to be rainfall
we could see wind gusts to 80 85 however
rainfall could be six to 12 inches some
places picking up as much as
18 inches of rain so do not drive
through water if you don't know how deep
it is all right next let's head to the
pacific and talk about douglas douglas
has been a monster
category 3 storm it's beginning to
weaken it's a cat 2.
it's about 900 miles to the east of the
big island of hawaii
it looks like it's going to skirt the
northern end of the island either as a
tropical storm
or a hurricane so watch out for
hurricane conditions there
and pounding surf in huge waves and
lastly i want to talk about gonzalo
gonzalo
luckily is weakening a lot it is
really weak right now winds are only 40
miles an hour and it is going to die
probably in the caribbean graveyard over
the next couple of days but watch out in
trinidad and tobago
and i want to leave you with this take a
look at this map across the atlantic
ocean right now
everywhere you see the yellow or orange
that's above normal temperatures
everywhere you see the blue that's below
normal temperatures almost the whole
basin is above
normal it is on fire in record territory
right now this is like
jet fuel and steroids for storms this is
likely to be one of the most active
hurricane seasons on record
and as you pointed out only only
entering august right now jeff
thank you very much